well I got a cinematic universe for
everything else so now Godzilla came out
and now King Kong is out now they're
going to build a King Kong Godzilla
Cinematic Universe alright here we go
[Music]
Kong install island become Skull Island
is King Kong side of the story
yeah Godzilla came out a couple years
ago point is enough people watched it to
where they were like let's make a King
Kong movie and one day has a to fight so
now we have this King Kong movie Kong
Skull Island area yeah I do want to get
into what I liked about the movie
alright first of all when King Kong is
on screen it's rat right when the
helicopters go to Skull Island they're
like all right we need to drop these
charges you see King come pretty early
just as you saw him in the trailer he
starts throwing trees through the
helicopters beating the [ __ ] out of the
helicopter he's like why'd you come to
my land he's pretty much like the old
guy in the cul-de-sac who doesn't bother
anybody or do anything chases ruffians
out of the yard with a stick that's King
Kong so now you show up dropping bombs
King Kong gets pissed he steps outside
he's like get off my lawn but that's
when you see him you see him there you
see him a couple of the times sprinkled
throughout the movie and then he has his
big throw down at the end and he's gone
generally speaking for the majority in
this movie you're stuck with the people
landed I know what you're thinking
that's what they did with Godzilla and I
really enjoyed Godzilla because in the
end as a whole of Godzilla was a better
story told better and although they're
not showing Godzilla thing pissed me off
he had a very gratifying throw down at
the end and I'd like the characters more
Godzilla yeah a lot of people didn't I'm
saying the characters in Godzilla were
much better than the characters in this
movie there's when we have great actors
you have Tom Hiddleston samuel l.jackson
John Goodman brie Larson Toby Kebbell
only [ __ ] how can this go wrong goes
wrong from the script writing because no
one gives a [ __ ] about these people why
are they in it why dude gives a [ __ ]
yeah just dropping around with them
walking through the fogs and the
shrubbery it's like you're supposed to
know that King Kong is out there
somewhere and that's supposed to make it
worth it does there's even a scene where
Tom Hiddleston he's a bird I don't think
he's using sword has he think someone
throws him a sword he puts on a gas mask
and he is straight-up ninja with this
sword alright I guess those guys really
super efficient with a sword in fact in
the movie he's super efficient at
everything all the time this is one of
those moments where my optimism kind of
just it didn't bite me in the ass but
I'm like hey I was wrong
that was hopeful and raw in the trailer
that showed a lot of humor with john c
reilly a lot of people were like that
doesn't look like your humor is going to
mix well I'm scared and I was like whoa
guys come on here we're giving a good
work not really doesn't john c reilly
has a couple of really good moments in
this movie that they showed in the
trailer and he has some other moments
that don't really land and there are a
lot of other moments of humor that are
attempted in this movie not with john c
reilly that just don't land at all this
really has conceptual brilliant in it
you know i mean conceptually speaking
it's a neat concept to have samuel
l.jackson character on a witch hunt for
this king kong ultimately he's captain
ahab one is just don't give a [ __ ]
because you don't give a [ __ ] about any
characters man granted in the peter
jackson king kong it concentrated on the
people for the majority of the movie
also difference is the peter jackson
king kong is a better movie overall it
actually gave the thing some humanity it
attempted to be a fulfilling movie as a
whole is really does exactly what you
think they're going to do once they
announce the fact that it's going to tie
over with godzilla and that is it exists
for the sake of time king kong into a
future godzilla movie and gives you none
of the fulfillment that a king kong
movie could give you the soundtrack was
good i'll say the soundtrack was really
good not in me it works in the movie
kind of i don't know how many times they
played a musical device to have Vietnam
War era music start blaring all their
going out there looking for someone or
the trying to destroy [ __ ] I just like
Dee would you do that
would you just concentrate on the goal
at hand I don't know all I know is when
I was listening to the music I was like
this soundtrack is worth looking into
guys in the end Kong Skull Island yeah
it is one let me down the pacing was
choppy it was shoddy it was all over the
place it concentrated on the human
characters which should be a good thing
all the human characters who gives a
[ __ ] about the movie could have made you
give a [ __ ] about them but it did Glenn
Kong was on screen wrecking anything it
was actually really cool to watch that
was fun but in the end it just didn't
pay off I was just bored for the
majority of this movie the pacing sucks
and I will say Kong Skull Island's
probably a better time if you're drunky
and now it's a flirty good you're
picking guys I'm cool throw down [ __ ] it
did have some cool throw down [ __ ] it
also had a lot of boring [ __ ] I actually
want to know for sure I want someone to
clock in time the screen time of King
Kong in Kong Skull Island and Godzilla
in Gaza
and tell me who actually has more screen
time all right guys so Kong Skull Island
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what monster movie do you
want to see next rampage they're making
that by the way they're making that but
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]